kein aufweichen der schuldenbremse
[Applaus]
im höchst steuer land dürfen wir die
steuern nicht weiter erhöhen außer jetzt
vielleicht für google und andere denn
sonst geht es zu lasten privater
investitionen und neue jobs und zum
anderen angesichts von inflationsrisiken
und der bereits bestehenden hohen
schulden kein aufweichen der
schuldenbremse
ich würde mir wünschen ein programm zur
beschleunigung des wirtschaftlichen
aufschwungs durch gezielte anreize in
klimaschutz in digitalisierung zu
investieren und zwar nicht vom staat
sondern in der breite der wirtschaft vom
handel über das handwerk die industrie
bis hin zum solo selbst stellen
deutschland hat keine zeit zu verlieren
vieles liegen geblieben die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung läuft
woanders besser als bei uns deshalb
sollte es rasch gehen